yeah we have a trailer for Captain
Marvel the second trailer for Captain
Marvel what is it about the Captain
Marvel trailers who's cutting these
things together why do they suck granted
no one promised that this one was gonna
break the Internet then I see this I'm
like it's the same trailer as the last
trailer this ain't as a trailer it's
yeah you know what I probably better I'm
probably just a little sour because it
took away the thing I liked about the
first trailer I thought she genuinely
punched an old lady
that's a scroll I guess alright well
knew it was gonna be a scroll could I
just hope that it was an old lady and no
old ladies are not all helpless Betty
White would kick her [ __ ] ass but
back to the underwhelming nature of the
Captain Marvel trailers the first one
and this one yeah I hold two this is the
same trailer they both have the same
[ __ ] to remembers a little bit of her
patch who remembers being a pilot
montage falling down montage standing up
Captain Marvel hang it upside down
Captain Marvel double fisting and
Captain Marvel being Opie at the end
that's it but this both trailers we
learned in this trailer they're
officially Scrolls we knew that from the
first trailer but now I guess we
officially know so that's a reveal
that's new I don't want to pull the old
man card and give you way back in my day
kind of speech but I do remember a time
when teaser trailers came out and they
were vague and they had a certain feel
to them they know later trailer would
come out and would show a lot more you
got a feel for the world but still it
didn't spoil and show everything there
was some Goldilocks zone that trailers
used to hit so the fact that this
trailer is exactly like the last trailer
I have to assume that they're hiding a
huge secret there's gonna be the biggest
reveal in Marvel history ever in Captain
Marvel so big in fact it's gonna be like
Captain Marvel's actually Thanos himself
herself has to be because otherwise the
other alternative is that there's no
real reveal
there's nothing they're trying to hide
and both these Captain Marvel trailers
are identical and underwhelming a [ __ ]
because all right Marvel Disney I know
what you're doing I get it mmm I ain't
no snitch I won't tell people I won't
tell people that you're plotting the
greatest reveal in cinematic history
won't tell us all but just know I know
we grated that shot at the end was
actually pretty cool her flying around
in shooting things I feel like I'm
bitter I just after the last trailer
underwhelming I was looking forward to
this trailer to see Marvel taking all
the feedback and go all right we're
really gonna knock him dead with this
one just to be this disappointed there's
gonna be another trailer there's gonna
be about four more trailers by the time
the movie does come out we'll see what
they have in store well I was Nick Fury
an idiot in this trailer at the very
least why is he Ace Ventura pet
detective
boom is you busy judging nothing in the
nick fury that we know points to him
ever doing that it's a really weird call
is this gonna be a buddy cop movie where
Nick Fury is gonna be like the funny one
I mean granted I'd stop and pet the cat
but that's me like do I lose Authority
do I look like I'm going to be the
leader of shield no I don't I do not
lose Authority there's at no point would
you see these videos would be like that
guy should be the leader of a government
organization that's why I would stop in
baby talk a cat in the middle of the
mission I feel like that was at a place
for Nick Fury anyhow I'm done bitching
about it over the next trailers better
or hope to have a huge reveal that
they're obviously hiding we shall see
alright so the second Captain Marvel
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]